Hello, hello! How are you?
What a pleasure
to greet you all!
Hi, everyone.
My name is Esteban Macías
and I'm here
in my beautiful Mexico City,
the great Tenochtitlan.
And here we are.
I'm so excited to be
joined by some of the stars
and the filmmakers
of Marvel Studios'
Black Panther:
Wakanda Forever.
I love how that sounds.
It sounds fantastic.
We're going to be talking
all about the new movie,
including a few questions
submitted by you, the fans,
but first, please let me
give you a warm welcome
and introductions to the half...
To the folks joining us today.
So, first of all,
Mr. Director, Ryan Coogler.
Mr. Producer, Nate Moore.
And what a front row we have.
What a front row.
Letitia Wright,
Shuri in the movie.
We have Nakia, Lupita Nyong'o,
which I know
understands everything
I'm saying in Spanish
and I love that.
And of course, Mabel Cadena,
which is Namora,
the new character in this movie.
-Welcome, Mabel...
-Thank you.
...to our country,
to Mexico City.
And unfortunately
I gotta tell you that Tenoch,
Tenoch Huerta,
couldn't join us today,
but we know he's proud
and excited for everyone
to come watch
this cast November 11th.
Tenoch couldn't be
with us today.
He sent us a little message,
but he expects us all
to see the film
this November 11th.
He's very excited
about this cast,
and well,
how about we get started?
We welcome you to Mexico City.
Welcome to Mexico City.
And I have to tell you,
guys, I'm a huge Marvel fan,
I love the MCU.
Of course, this new movie
I think it's great.
I got the chance to see it
yesterday and I loved it.
And what about
we start with you, Ryan?
First of all,
I want to ask you, of course,
Ryan, Nate, and for everyone.
The first one
was a huge spectacle,
but I don't know how you do it.
This one looks bigger.
Action scenes, new characters,
a lot of new locations,
so tell me how it was
to return to Wakanda,
but also to bring
to this new movie
the huge
and lovely city of Talokán.
How was it?
It was, it was fantastic
to have the opportunity to work
with these actors again,
to have a chance to deepen
our relationship
with the characters,
see new parts of Wakanda,
and it was...
It was truly amazing
to be able to bring
Talokán to the big screen.
Especially the characters,
Namor, Namora, Attuma.
It was fantastic for me
and I think
I was not in the minority
of folks involved
with the film
who are the best swimmers.
I had to commit to learn
how to swim so I could be there
with the actors
and with the camera team
and the underwater team.
I think Nate kind of
figured it out before.
But it was, it was
just an amazing opportunity.
And also to learn
more about the cultures
of Mesoamerica,
the pre-Columbian
history of Mesoamerica
and to make
friends with new talented folks
from different parts
of the world like Mabel,
Tenoch, and Alex.
It was truly,
it was truly a fantastic
opportunity and a blessing.
[Esteban]
For you, Nate, how was,
-how was filming?
-Yeah,
it was really exciting.
I mean, you know.
When Ryan brought to us
what he thought
the second movie could be,
it was impressive and daunting
because whenever you
think about creating,
not only revisiting Wakanda,
but creating this new world
of Talokán that is underwater,
you realize there's a whole host
of other logistical questions
you're going to have to answer.
And Ryan is such
a grounded filmmaker
and wanted everything
to feel tactile
and wanted performers
to be in the water,
to really move as if they were
in submerged environments
which just created
an interesting extra wrinkle
past mid the movie
of all these water tanks
and training people
to be comfortable
performing in water,
but I think all that
fidelity shows up on screen.
And so, when you watch
the movie, hopefully,
audiences are really
immersed in this world
because the actors
and actresses are really there.
Were you expecting that,
Lupita, Letitia?
The brand new worlds
coming to this movie?
Not at all.
I mean, when Ryan told me
what the idea was,
I was kind of shocked
and confused.
I mean,
when you read the script,
you're just like "Well,
how are we going to make
half this movie underwater?"
You know? It just seems like a
very impossible task
to do, but then I remembered
also how much
Ryan likes water
'cause in the first
film we had water.
-A lot of water.
-We had water.
He keeps... And then
it was water to our shins,
and then decided to just
submerge us entirely.
But I was also
very excited to have that
opportunity to learn
how to befriend the water,
how to be comfortable
in the water
because I think
that's a very important skill
and one that I think
too often we overlook.
Indeed. I want
to ask you, Mabel.
I'm going to ask this in Spanish
because we're in Mexico City.
We're in Mexico.
Well, what was it like
to join this group
and play this character?
It was amazing, really,
because I never expected
to have an opportunity
like this. And I worked
so hard to be proud
of the career
that I have today in this city,
in this country,
and receiving this opportunity
helped me remind myself
that I had to work and develop
new skills, you know?
That I could make new paths
possible for myself.
I'm so grateful to Nate,
to Ryan,
to this whole team
because for me
it was a "Hey, Mabel.
Remember that you can
change the pace and the story
of your own life," you know?
"Remind yourself.
Remember your power,
remember your ability
to create new worlds," you know?
So it opened up
a whole universe for me
that was maybe
impossible before.
It was like, "No,
I'm never going to be there."
It was like "I have
to deal with a language
that's not mine, I have to deal
with a lot of things
that seem
a little bit impossible"
and this was like
"Oh, my God, I'm here!
With this team,
with this amazing director
and with this amazing producer,
and they give me all the tools
for made this story
real for me."
So I'm very grateful for that.
And it's fantastic to see
a Mexican such as yourself
in a movie like this one.
It's so great.
Ryan and Nate, how was to...
Or the approach
to bring back Wakanda
and the world of Wakanda,
but at the same time
honoring the memory
of Chadwick Boseman
and respecting his huge legacy?
Yeah, I mean...
I can say none of us obviously
expected to lose Chad and so...
You know, there's
a version of this movie
where his character
was a big part of it,
but once we all felt
that loss we were able
to kind of process
what it meant,
we had to figure out
how to recenter the movie
in a way that both
respected us as artists
and didn't force us into places
we were uncomfortable with,
but also gave audiences
the opportunity to revisit
a world they loved, you know?
I think
I would go as far... Like,
Chad understood what Wakanda
meant to people,
so we had to figure out
how to revisit that place,
but also infuse
into the storytelling
the very real loss
we were feeling,
the loss that I think
audiences were feeling too.
And so we tried to tell
a story that was honest
to those emotions
and that allowed the characters
to grieve the loss of T'Challa
in the same way we were
grieving the loss of the man.
And so, giving them the choice,
the question became
how do we best tackle this,
again, in a way
that expanded the legacy
of the man in the world,
but allowed us to deliver
something we could believe in.
Letitia, you were so close
to him in the first movie,
so in that regard, how was
coming back to this world?
So, yeah. The first conversation
was discussing with...
With my director
how we were going to...
We were going to come together
as a team to honor my bro
and at first it was
really weird for me
'cause I was still...
I was just really angry
at the world.
I was just really upset
and I just didn't...
I just didn't want to do it
without him.
And I just had to...
I just really had to trust
my director.
I had to trust him
as our leader, as our brother.
Someone who is
incredibly sensitive
and instinctive as well.
He's really instinctive
about his choices.
He doesn't just
make it just to make it,
so I knew when he was saying
"There's a light here
that we could tap into..."
That changed my perspective
and I saw the opportunity
to honor my brother
in a way that I didn't before.
I was just angry and upset
and I just turned that around
to how can I give
the best of myself
and give the best
of this character that,
you know, predominantly,
he chose to be his...
You know,
he chose to be his sister.
How can I do my best
in this film alongside my team,
to be honorable to him,
and that's how
we tackled it together.
And I would say that's
the best way to pay an homage,
working around it.
The tribute paid
to Chadwick Boseman
in the film is truly fantastic.
It's so great.
Let's change
a little bit of mood.
I want to talk about the music
because these mixes
between the African rhythms
and these flutes
from the Mesoamerican cultures
and the Mayan rhythms,
what can you tell me, Ryan,
what do you want to do
with the music
in Wakanda Forever?
[Ryan] Yeah...
We were able to work
with Ludwig Goransson,
who was our composer
on the last film.
I have a long working
relationship with him and...
We try to work in a way
that's organic and holistic.
We want to give audiences
a unique experience
and we also wanted
to make sure that,
since we were exploring
another culture
and representing
another culture,
that we did the same
type of work that we did
for the first film
in representing
the cultures of Africa
in Wakanda.
So Ludwig immediately
read the first draft
of the script
and booked time here
in Mexico City
and also in the Yucatan region,
out of country,
worked with musicians
that were from here
in terms of making
contemporary songs,
but also he worked
with musical archeologists,
who kind of dedicated
their lives to the study
of the types of music
that Mesoamericans
would've made art with
during the pre-Columbian times.
And that part, I think,
was the most interesting
because we found that a lot
of the motives of the film
were present in the sonic scapes
of the people from that time.
For instance,
seashells, you know,
were a massive part
of how they made music
and it made a lot of sense
obviously because Talokán
is now in the ocean in the MCU,
so that really opened things up.
It would blew my mind
how much they sounded
like French horns
with the humanity that we had
and the Fula flutes that we used
for Killmonger's theme
-in the first film.
-Yeah.
So it was fantastic. We were
also able to dig deeper
into the music of the continent
with both contemporary sound
and also use some
of the more traditional music.
I mean, it was
a fantastic opportunity
and I think it's some
of Ludwig's best works
to be honest.
Beautiful shells
that you find...
In the movie.
Nakia and Shuri are...
beacons of inspiration.
I think those characters
inspire a lot of people
around the globe,
so first, how was
experiencing
that inspiration you provide
with the characters and also,
in any sense, did that change
the way you approach
the character
for this new movie?
It's very touching when
people relate to your character
and cite your character
as a source of inspiration,
you know? In the first film,
we had so many female figures
who were so different
from one another for...
To be role models or people,
you know?
There's a good population
of women in this story
that allow for young girls,
young people,
to identify with one or another.
Kids say "I relate to your
character Nakia for X reason"
or "I want to do STEM
thanks to Shuri"
and it's lovely to be able
to be the vessel
for that kind of...
That kind of inspiration.
And for this film, of course,
I think the death of Chadwick
really changed the direction
that we were going
with this film
and it became part of the
evolutions of the characters
so, in this film, you know,
Nakia has matured,
she's lost someone
near and dear to her.
She's navigating her
grief in a special way,
in a distinct way from,
say, how Shuri is doing it.
And I think that having those
distinctions of how people
deal with grief
in the first place
is also extremely
helpful and healthy
because grief doesn't look
the same on everyone.
It's a very...
It's a condition
with lots of colors
and our film
showcases or explores grief
in a number of different
and very helpful ways.
All this, Letitia,
changed the way
you approach the character?
Yeah, for sure.
In connection to what
Lupita just shared,
I'm so beautifully
seeing so many young girls
be empowered by these women
and not forcing it,
you know what I mean?
Like, we didn't do the film
to get a particular result.
We just wanted
to tell the truth.
And I think when you do that,
people receive it, like, better?
'Cause you're not trying
to force it down their throats,
it's just like, we're just,
we're just existing
in a world that is equal,
in a world that
naturally you just feel
empowered when you look
at these characters on screen
so that's the same for this one.
And yeah, it is tricky
because we're looking at...
We're looking
at the ways in which
these beautiful women
from the first film
are impacted by someone
that they loved so much,
so yes, it would cause you
to approach a character
a little bit differently.
But at the same time,
again, just staying on the path
of telling the truth
and that truth, again,
can inspire and can also lead
to many people feeling healed
as well from touching into...
Touching into the ways
in which these characters
are dealing with this situation.
-Yes.
-Well, Mabel,
what does it mean to you
to play this character,
which also has Mexican roots
and presenting her
in Mexico City?
What does it mean?
To see me. To see me
and embrace me
for the first time
and embrace my power.
I think there's
no better movie like this.
There's no better movie
like Black Panther
to introduce a world
like what Talokán is.
To introduce a diversity
of faces, of colors,
of shapes, you know?
I think it's amazing
that a movie like this can start
to show beautiful faces,
beautiful women
and powerful men around Mexico,
Latin America and the world.
And embracing our cultures
and our origins,
you know? I mean,
we're talking about
the fact that maybe
we're different stories,
but we have the same movement,
we are moved by the same needs.
I have the need for many
girls and boys to feel that,
even if I didn't have
the opportunity before to dream
that I could be part
of a film like this,
I don't want children today
to question that
they can dream about it.
I want adults to be able
to see their stories,
their languages, their origins,
their music represented.
And I think to be part
of a movie like this,
to bring Talokán,
with Tenoch, with Alex,
with all this universe that
was part of what changed the...
That legacy of Black Panther
can give us the hope
of representing
a diversity
of stories in our cinema
around the world,
not only in Mexico.
And I agree with you.
And I gotta say,
Ryan and Nate, as Mexican,
to see
those references in the movie,
so well respected,
it's fantastic
and I'm grateful for that.
But how hard was the process
to come to that conclusion,
of what are we
going to be seeing
in this submerged city,
in this beautiful Talokán?
I mean, I think once Ryan
had the idea
to sort of anchor
the world of Talokán
in Mesoamerican culture
and really be inspired
both by ancient
Mayan civilization
and present day
Mayan civilization,
then it's just the process
of finding the right consultants
to help us try to get it
as right as we can,
you know? I don't think
any of us pretend
to be historians,
but you do want,
if you're going to pay
homage to a place,
you do want to get it right
so we worked with,
you know, Dr. Aldana,
who's an academic
out of the US who spent
a lot of time in the region.
We had an on-set interpreter
for Yucatec Mayan dialect
so that Mabel, Tenoch, and Alex
always had a touchstone
of someone
who is from the region
who could speak it correctly,
but I think trying
to get those details
as right as possible
hopefully will build
a world that people
feel is as cared for
as Wakanda is
because it's important
when you're,
if you're seeing Talokán,
as referenced earlier,
you don't want it to feel
like we didn't take the time
because really is a love letter
to both of these worlds.
And you brought back Ruth Carter
in that same order of ideas,
so I...
I don't know. I assume
she was very important
to closure everything.
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Ruth was back,
Hannah Beachler was back,
we worked with a great
visual development team
that works at Marvel Studios
supervised by Ryan,
and I feel...
[murmuring]
Yeah. Like...
So we had, we had all these
incredible professionals
who we had relationships with.
We knew each other's
dispositions
when it came to work
so it was actually
fantastic to get back to it.
And I gotta say,
you know, yesterday I was able
to go to the museum
that's like right
across from our hotel,
and we went to the Mayan
exhibit with my family
and it was actually
astonishing to see
all the things that Dr. Aldana
had shown us, like, pictures,
some of the things
we kind of rebuilt.
To see the actual things,
it was like...
It was the most, maybe one
of the most surreal experiences
I've ever had as a filmmaker,
you know? 'Cause
we made this film
during the pandemic.
It was not easy
to travel to the places
the same way we did
on the first film.
So we were mostly traveling
digitally, you know what I mean?
Looking at Google Earth,
and looking at photographs.
We were 3D printing things.
And it was, to walk in there
and see the actual artifacts,
you know, from what
we studied, to see
the jade workings
and the headdresses
and all of the texts, you know?
To actually see
it was deeply moving.
It was deeply moving.
I felt like
a spiritual connection,
like, I felt like we did
the right thing, you know?
We made the right choices,
you never know.
I think that, for me,
the idea of consulting work,
like, the industry, you know?
The industry of saying
I'm not letting the fact
that you don't know
be an excuse not to do it,
you know what I mean? Like,
going to find the people
who know, paying them,
you know what I mean?
And letting them inform
what was happening.
I hope that we can be examples
of a new type of filmmaking
-at this level we're making.
-[Letitia] Love that.
Before we go
to the fans' questions,
and regarding the fans
and everything,
what are you most excited about
for the fans
to see in Wakanda Forever?
-Me?
-Yeah.
-Wow.
-That's a...
You're the man!
I mean, there's several of us,
you know what I mean?
No, it's you. It's you.
What I would say...
It's hard for me to pick
one thing, you know?
A lot went into this.
A lot was sacrificed
by everyone,
individually, collectively.
I've never been as proud
of a movie as this
and I've been working
for over a third of my life,
you know what I'm saying?
In this medium.
When I watch the film,
I feel the love that we have
for each other, the love
that we have for the medium,
the love that we have
for our dearly departed friend.
And I also feel
the wish to connect with people,
you know what I mean?
I feel it. Like,
as we were showing
the film to people,
I think that part works,
like, people would say "Hey,
this film reminds me of when
I lost this person that I love"
or "This film reminds
me when I was going through
this emotion or when I was
coming of age in this way."
So I'm actually looking
forward to audiences
just having a good time
at the movies,
but also connecting to what
we were feeling at the time.
And now let's move on
to the fan questions.
And the first one
is for you, Mabel.
It says, "how would you
describe the relationship
between Namora and Namor?"
For me it's such a beautiful
relationship because,
all of a sudden,
I feel Namora so visceral
and so ready
to protect her people,
to go to war to give her life
for Namor and all this,
that when she has to calm down
and listen to him,
then you mix two generations,
you know?
The wisdom of their God,
of the person who has passed on
to her this protective thing,
loyalty, love for her people,
for her nation, for her culture,
but who at the same time
passes on to her this wisdom
that only someone like him
can have
and who passes on to her
another kind of knowledge.
So, mixing
these two relationships,
these two ways of seeing life,
seems to me one
of the most beautiful things.
I tried to work with Tenoch
to build our relationship
because we said
"Let's put a little bit
of our Mexican culture.
We Mexicans are family,
we are warm,
we are protective, loyal."
So, we were trying
to have gestures
of being a family,
of being warriors,
of taking care of each other,
of standing up for our people,
for our nation.
That's so nice!
The next question
is for you, Letitia.
They say "Shuri is such
an incredible character.
Fans would like to know
what can they expect from her
in Wakanda Forever?"
We can expect a young woman
going through the journey
of womanhood.
We can expect to see
Shuri in ways
that we never thought
we would have before.
There's a maturity to her
that's really lovely.
It can speak
to a lot of young people
who are probably
on that same path as well.
And we can expect
a lot of her lively,
bubbly self, but just it's...
There's...
Real things
that she's dealing with
in comparison to the first film
and we see the ways
in which she handles that
and hopefully it can be
of inspiration
and healing to others.
Can expect a lot more still,
but you gotta see it.
You gotta see it when
it comes out this weekend.
And I'm going to allow
myself to do this.
Lupita, this question is for you
and they told me
to ask it in Spanish.
Okay.
First of all,
they say they love you.
Heart emoji and everything,
very nice.
And then they ask "how did you
react when you found out
that Black Panther 2 was going
to highlight Mexican culture,
that you were going to speak
a little bit of Spanish
-in the movie?"
-Yes.
It surprised me,
but I also...
Felt very grateful?
Is that how you say it?
Yeah, thankful to Ryan
for doing that
because for a long time, I...
I've wanted to speak
Spanish in a movie
and I never imagined
it was going to happen
with Black Panther.
So I read the script
and I saw the Spanish words
and I felt very...
Very... How do you say it?
-Pride.
-Yes! Of course.
I was proud of doing it.
Well, that's fantastic.
We thank you,
our dear adopted Mexican.
Of course.
And Ryan, I want to ask you
about this part,
of bringing the Spanish
and the Mayan world,
why was that
very important for you?
Why was it important?
Yeah. Language
is a big motif
in these films,
this series of films.
This idea of how
the active conquest,
historical conquest
or colonization can affect
the way that people speak.
It was an idea that
actually Nate and...
Chad I think
discussed in Civil War,
even before
I was hired, you know?
And I can't express
the joy I felt
when I watched Civil War
for the first time.
I saw a very early cut.
We were trying to figure out
if we were going to work
together, and my mind was blown
when T'Challa and T'Chaka
spoke to each other
at the UN in a language,
it was a language
that I had never heard before,
a South African dialect.
And I immediately thought "Wow,
they invented
a language for the movie."
You know what I'm saying?
"This sounds awesome."
And I talked to Nate,
like a few minutes
after I watched the movie,
and he was like "No,
that's actually the language
that the actor
that we casted spoke."
And I was like "First of all,
that was one of the most
beautiful languages
I've ever heard.
Second of all, this is awesome."
Because the films that
I loved when I was young
often gave an additional
respect to languages,
even when it didn't have to.
I think when watching
the Tolkien adaptations
that Peter Jackson did,
when the elves speak
their own language
and you feel like the geo...
I think geopolitical film
is the best way
you understand
why people communicate
and why they're entirely
different.
And especially these films,
we kind of let colonization
be a thing that we wrestle with,
it became
all the more important.
It's very important in America
as it is on the continent,
you know?
You can learn a lot
about people by how they speak.
As we learn more about Mayan
culture and learn that...
A large Mayan population
is still in this place
and they
still speak the language.
It's something
they hold on to with pride.
It made a lot of sense to make
sure that the Talokánians
held on to that as well,
especially due
to Namor's character.
It felt like he was
a person that was trying
to hold onto
everything that he could.
So we took it seriously.
It's like seven languages
spoken in the movie.
-[Ryan] Yeah.
-[Lupita] Wow.
We had a lot to follow
with that.
I'm a monolingual director,
you know what I'm saying?
So it was not
without complications.
Not without unintentional
humor at times.
We have Josue, who's,
you know, many times
the only person on set
who spoke fluent Mayan.
Man, he was working hard.
You know what I mean?
We would bring him in
to watch cuts of the movie
and he was like "No,
you gotta fix this."
-Yeah.
-"What they're saying
is not what you want them
to say."
But he had a deep,
I think, as all Mayans do,
as he was explaining to me,
he had a very deep, deep,
deep sense of duty
to make sure we got this right.
And he would not...
Hesitate to stress that upon us
and to stress upon the actors.
"It's very important
that you do this the right way."
I was honored.
I feel a deep sense of gratitude
because I cannot imagine
being the only person
on the set having to represent
my whole culture amongst people
who are not as familiar with it
as necessary and I hope
we did those languages
and those cultures justice,
you know what I'm saying?
Well, the truth is that
you have to be very,
very excited about
this movie, everyone.
If you weren't already
hyped up enough,
I think now they're going to be
even more excited
to see this movie and check
all of your incredible,
incredible work
in Wakanda Forever.
Thank you all so much.
I hope you enjoyed
your time in Mexico City.
Please, Lupita, eat tacos,
pozole, and quesadillas.
You gotta try everything.
Thank you very much
for being here with us.
And thank you all for watching!
We can't wait for everyone
to experience the movie.
Get your tickets now
for Marvel Studios'
Black Panther: Wakanda Forever
in theaters everywhere.
-Bye, bye. Thank you.
-Thank you.